the holidays are fast approaching and
that means family gatherings and parties
with friends and to celebrate we caught
up with two audience members who happen
to be bffs earlier today to show them
how to get a quick holiday do that is
sure to impress take a look
hi how are you how are you min it's so
nice to see you same i can't wait to
show you everything that we're going to
be doing by the way you guys are
really good friends right we are like
besties it's my work wife
so a good hair day
is a very powerful thing it is and the
confidence that comes with it is
liberating as well as empowering it's
literally the crown on our head i'm
excited to see min what you're gonna do
the drew barrymore show has teamed up
with l'oreal professional and i'm going
to work on their hair using the l'oreal
professional steam pod do you think that
this is a tool that's less intimidating
because some hair tools i think if
you're not a professional you sort of
look at it and you're like what do i do
exactly with this yes it's user friendly
and i love how much versatility
you get with the different types of
textures and the types of waves or even
the way you smooth it where do we begin
well leah it's been ages and she's had
her hair smoothed out so what i'm going
to do is add a half up style with the
french clip which won't disturb it but
will also give her a different vibe for
the evening look or if she's going to a
party
and for jerica i'm going to give her
something a little bit special by adding
different types of ways so it's a really
casual look that we're going to make
come to life so i think it's going to be
really exciting to show the
transformation on these lovely ladies
and also to show them how to use it on
themselves well i can't wait to learn
too by the way
teach me
i'll see you guys at the end of the show
i can't wait to see the end results
history begins ladies
so we want to make sure when we're
passing the steam pot through that the
arrows are pointing down this is because
we're combining the power of steam with
the comb
which is going to smooth the hair
do you love how like the hair is supple
i'm just in shock it's still got body
and it's like super soft looking good
so i'll show you how i do the wave that
i have on my hair
go back
and forth oh
and it creates like a s pattern
and with your hair being layered i think
it's a nice thing to mix up the
different types of waves that you have
you can wrap it
unwind
when you're creating fast and easy
gorgeous styles this is my go-to and it
can help you to create a lot of
different looks for the holidays i love
that it's gonna be a new woman
okay
i am so excited to see how their hair
turned out and mim is joining me here in
the studio now
um let's see a quick look before
okay i can't wait to see what you did
for these transformations okay drew wait
till you see their hair well let's see
it leah and jerica come on out
oh
my
gosh
okay first of all leah your hair is six
feet longer so much longer yes
like literally it's crazy because i
hadn't straightened it for two years so
i yeah i don't recognize myself
how do you feel i love my natural curls
but it's definitely fun to be able to
switch it up every once in a while so i
like it yeah yeah the combination of the
steam and the comb really helps to give
you that control it's fast and easy and
the shine is incredible so yeah and
healthy jerica how do you feel i love it
my hair is naturally like so straight so
it feels awesome to have like bouncy
waves and it feels like
fun
also it frames your face really
beautifully like i see you know why
professional people
take an approach where they're giving
sort of
you know this heart shape to our face
and she taught me different ways to do
different curls so i i can't wait to
try that when i go get one
what's a tip to keeping your hair
looking like this
days after the party can we hold on to
this look you 100
can and i'd say the first thing i'm
going to tell you ladies to do is to get
yourself a silk pillowcase
so this way your hair it doesn't stick
or get ruffled up on your regular
pillowcases
and then the second thing is to get a
dry shampoo so that will extend the life
and soak up any oil or anything that
might be happening at her scalp okay
good tip thank you
well leah and jerica we want to send you
both home with the l'oreal professional
steam pods so that you can rock these
looks
at your upcoming parties and these steam
pods are worth 250
oh wow thank you i know
yeah and guess what
everyone in our audience is gonna get
one too
thank you nin thank you leah thank you
jericho
[Music]
you